- Mr beast literally puts
his life on the line,
with so many of his challenges.
And we're going to talk about
that as well as #TeamSeas.
- [Mr Beast] A marathon is 26 miles
and today with no prior training,
we're going to attempt it
with the world's largest pair of shoes.
- I'm nervous already because
two problems arise here.
One, running a marathon
with no prior training,
incredibly bad for your body.
Now I'm not just talking about
your joints, your muscles,
your tendons, I'm talking
about your kidneys.
When you have a rapid
breakdown of muscle tissue,
which happens during a marathon
because of the tremendous
stress your body's under,
you actually break down
that muscle tissue,
releasing myoglobin,
which is actually toxic to your kidney.
No joke, I've seen
people who were untrained
run a marathon and then pee blood after.
- Wow.
(laughing)
- And then running in these shoes
obviously that's ridiculous.
My man, everything's going to hurt.
Anything you put into your shoe,
the amount of foam there,
the flexibility of your soul
that will affect your ankle,
then your knee, then your
hip, then your low back.
- Each of these shoes, weighs five pounds,
that's 10 pounds in total.
- You know, what's going to
probably be sorest on him,
knees for one by far, also on
his anterior tibialis muscle,
because that's the muscle
that has to bring the shoe up,
in order for you to take
a step without tripping,
and it's going to be even
worse with this giant shoe.
- This shoe was constantly
scraping the side of my feet
and it was getting extremely painful.
So we had to do some modification.
- So they're wearing a shoe over shoe.
Do you see how important
proper foot wear is?
The human body works through
a biomechanical motion
that has evolved over millions of years.
And it's all very well thought out.
It's a beautiful process action.
Your weight distribution,
how your foot strikes the floor,
how the muscles bear the
weight of that impact
and how your arch is supposed
to take in some of that force.
You negate all of that by
strapping this giant shoe
to the bottom of your foot.
- And this is Joey Chestnut.
- Ah, Joey Chestnut.
Joey Chestnut crushes it at
the Hot Dog Eating Contest.
(pizza crust crackling)
- What the freak is he doing?
- This is as fast as I can eat.
- Competitive food eaters
scare the life out of me,
because I have no idea how they consume
an absurd number of calories.
And don't A, put on weight B,
don't rupture their stomach.
It's just like a magnificent
feed. It's almost like magic.
Think how much salt is in there.
How much sodium is in there.
That's a huge load on your kidneys.
What do their bodies go through?
- [Man] There's no way I can do this, no.
- No, he does it so fast, too.
- One final bite. Oh my God!
Before we started, we weighed
him and he weighed 229.
Let's go see what he weighs now.
- That was one of the hardest
challenges in my life.
- Step on the scale.
Let's see how much weight you gained.
No way, he weighs 250.
- Well, he drank a lot of water too.
God, I can't imagine what
going to the bathroom
after that must be.
Not going to lie though,
I would probably fare pretty well at this.
(beeping sound)
- [Mr. Beast] We will be spending 24 hours
in this insane asylum.
- First of all, we don't
call the insane asylums.
We don't have insane asylums like this.
We actually also moved away
from using restraints in patients.
We prefer using someone
to watch over them.
Perhaps medication options
to help calm them down,
but this is just like really barbaric.
This is like what used
to happen 200 years ago.
- So were letting Chandler poop and...
- I tore my labrum and my shoulder
and like popped out of
socket and really hurt.
- How did he tear his labrum?
- Whoa!
The fact that his shoulder is dislocated
is a really big problem.
The most common form of
shoulder dislocations
are anterior shoulder dislocations.
You need to put them back
cause otherwise it's really a lot of pain.
- The doctor said that they're pretty sure
that I've blown either
one or both my eardrums,
because my eardrums are full
of pus and stuff like that
and I have an infection.
- This is a difficult explanation here.
He may or may not have blown an eardrum,
which you could see if you just
do an autoscope exam there,
if that's the case due to an infection,
that would be treatable with antibiotics.
So I'm not sure
if there's like a
eustachian tube dysfunction
that's also simultaneously going on,
which is the tube that connects
your sinuses to your ears,
which can make like popping sensations,
pressure differentials
become quite painful.
The idea that he has just
like nighttime ear pain,
randomly warrants further investigation,
or at least a better explanation for me.
- In this video, we will
be eating a $70,000 pizza.
- That's an expensive pizza.
- [Chef] An ounce of gold
that's covering the crust.
10 year old Parmesan milk.
Japanese beef has been marinated overnight
in a $ 10,000 dollar bottle...
- This is so ridiculous.
This is only in America.
Gold is an inert substance.
So it's going to just like go
through your digestive system
and you're going to poop it out.
Not something that I
recommend eating regularly.
Don't eat metal. Like guy,
that's a pretty standard
piece of medical advice.
(soothing music)
- Oh my God. Straight up.
I really, really like it.
- No way.
- So we're going to act
like my channel was hacked.
And the only way for me
to get my channel back,
is to raise a million dollars
through selling body parts and organ.
You see your body parts
are actually worth a lot.
- They are, but they're not legal to sell,
especially here in the United States.
There is actually one country
where you can sell your
organs and it is legal.
It's one country in the whole world, Iran.
- Kidneys are 200,000. Whoa!
I can get 200 grand for a kidney?
- You can live with one kidney,
but you have to be very
careful in that instance
because you got to take
care of your soul kidney.
You gotta watch out for
medications that you can take
that can negatively impact your kidneys.
Advil, Motrin, Aleve,
things that you wouldn't even realize,
could pose a serious,
serious risk to your kidneys.
- Skeletons, three to five grand now.
- Who is selling skeletons?
He's definitely reading like
a board game, nothing like,
it has nothing to do with reality.
- Liver. Okay, so
according to this article,
obviously you can't live without.
- No, you can't live without your liver,
but if your liver is
damaged, it does regenerate.
And if you cut pieces off, we
actually see it regenerate.
- So technically if I
donate half my liver,
the other half will grow back.
Therefore I'm definitely
selling half my liver.
So we're going to add that to the list.
- He has a Microsoft Word
file open selling his organ.
- According to this
article, people can survive,
even if an entire lung is removed.
- I actually had a friend growing up.
His dad was unfortunately
attacked in New York city
as a taxi cab driver, and he
was left with only one lung.
You can live with one lung.
- A gram of bone marrow,
is worth $23,000 on the black market.
- You could actually do bone
marrow donations even now,
for people who are battling cancer.
For example,
my mom needed bone marrow
donations from individuals.
So don't expect to get 23Gs though.
- I'm going to attempt to sit underwater,
for 24 hours straight.
- This one's painful to watch
because a lot happens here.
- So I have this tube right here,
and this tube is going to be
constantly feeding me oxygen.
- There's just so many
variables and stresses
that his body's going to have to face.
Like his skin is going to prune.
He's not moving well.
Cramps of his muscles.
He's also going to have
obviously sleep deprivation
because he's going to be out for 24 hours.
There's just a lot of
things that can go wrong
and very easy for him to feel unwell
and need to leave the challenge.
- Now my hands are so soggy.
- Oh my God!
- Also, I think this
is a chlorinated pool.
Extended exposure to chlorine,
actually can cause skin
irritation, damage rashes.
When you see individuals
spent a ton of time,
submerged in water,
their skin actually starts breaking down
and then they start getting
fungal and bacterial infections.
The skin prune thing,
is probably the most
interesting part of this video
because a lot of people
assume that the skin pruning
has something to do with
electrolytes or things like that.
That's what I even used to think.
This is an autonomic
nervous system response
that helps us better navigate
wet surfaces and wet objects.
And the way we actually found this out
is because we found those
who had nerve damage
to those areas, weren't pruning in water.
So it's crazy that our bodies have evolved
in order to help us
survive when we get wet
by giving us extra traction,
as if we had tires on our
feet, how cool is that?
- I need some air.
- Okay, I wish he had an
oxygen sensor in there
to know how much oxygen he's getting.
There may have been periods of time,
where there was a lot of CO2
in there, not enough oxygen.
He could have easily
started developing hypoxia
from lack of oxygen in there.
- The little update
and actually it's starting to
get a little freezing in here.
- The water being not body temperature,
even if it's 70 degrees,
you know, it may feel okay.
It can actually cause
you develop hypothermia
in like a few hours because
the water is so cold
and your body's not acclimated to this,
cause your natural body
temperature is around 98 degrees.
You can start developing hypothermia
because you aren't able to
keep your body temperature up.
- But I randomly started
feeling extremely sick
while sitting under water
and I had to come out.
Like I just had this
strong urge to throw up.
I think it's because the
water was constantly moving.
I was just getting really
seasick under there.
- Seasick, hypothermic, pruning,
hypoxic, not enough oxygen.
There's just so many variables in here
that make him feel unwell,
it's not surprising
that he had to come out.
- I'm gonna spend the next 50 hours,
buried alive in this coffin.
Probably the dumbest thing I've ever done.
- This one legit scares me
because he's going to be
trapped in there for awhile.
- Oh, stop.
- I got to imagine he fell through it
and he just fell right onto
his body, broke a rib. Oh!
- I tried to turn around,
it was like very narrow on the other end.
- I love that he has food and hydration.
That's all important.
I really hope he stays
mobile in this thing.
By not moving for long periods of time,
blood actually stagnates in your body,
especially in the lower extremities.
You can actually have clots
form that then can get loose,
shot up into your lungs and
cause a pulmonary embolism.
- You've officially made
it underground, 24 hours.
- Wow!
- Really?
- So how do you feel
after being in underground
for 24 hours?
- My back hurts, starting
to feel claustrophobic.
- Claustrophobia is a legit phobia.
A lot of people suffer with this.
It's one of the top phobias
in the United States.
When you're not moving,
you're putting pressure on certain areas.
You could actually develop bed sores.
For patients who are paralyzed,
we have to constantly reposition them.
Otherwise we have decreased
circulation of skin
to that area.
It starts getting red at first
and then it actually opens up as a sore.
It can turn black and like
a full hole in the body.
- I have to poop really bad,
but I've decided just to hold it.
- Not pooping for 48 hours
is not the end of the world.
You know, patients can go
a week without pooping.
And obviously that's like
a constipation diagnosis,
but it's not something
that is lethal or deadly.
(fireworks bursting)
This is probably the most
dangerous part of this video
because if any of that fireworks smoke
actually got into his coffin,
he can actually get really sick
from carbon monoxide poisoning very fast
and they might just think he fell asleep,
but he's actually developed
carbon monoxide poisoning.
That's one of the symptoms.
Do not allow smoke to
occur in an enclosed space.
That is literally deadly.
The reason I actually reacted
to all these Mr. Beast videos
is because I've teamed
up with him and creators
from all around the world
to promote Team Seas
and the international
effort to raise $30 million
to remove 30 million pieces
of trash from our oceans,
rivers and waterways.
All you have to do is
head over to teamseas.org,
to learn more and donate as little as $1
to remove one piece of trash,
or simply share this
video with the #TeamSeas
to help make sure that our
oceans are happy and healthy.
If you want to watch me
kick some butt and box,
literally box cause
I'm a doctor boxer now,
click here to check that out
and as always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)